10 ist weder ein spalter noch ein hetzer
sondern erfasst eine
gesellschaftspolitische diskussion
zusammen er nimmt sie auf die in der
bevölkerung jeden eigentlich
interessiert und jeden jedem stammtisch
nicht beherrscht sondern in der
täglichen diskussion ist und deswegen
ist das wichtig aus meiner sicht wäre es
sehr viel wichtiger wenn eine partei wie
die spd sich inhaltlich mit den
argumenten auseinandersetzt nicht über
einen parteiausschluss nicht mit druck
sondern über eine inhaltliche diskussion
und thilo sarrazin ist jemand der die
inhaltliche diskussion sicherlich
schärft voran ziert zusammenfasst und
das ist etwas was wir auch gerne weiter
in der spd haben wollen und sehen
möchten wir werden berufung zur
bundesschiedskommission einlegen
innerhalb einer frist von 14 tagen dann
wird eine begründung gegeben werden ich
vermute mal dass die
bundesschiedskommission vor der
sommerpause möglicherweise entscheiden
wird wir glauben an die kraft der
bundesschiedskommission dass
möglicherweise die
bundesschiedskommission die vorder
instanzen korrigieren wird
möglicherweise und in abhängigkeit von
der entscheidung der
bundesschiedskommission gibt es immer
noch die möglichkeit des ordentlichen
rechtsweges landgericht berlin
kammergericht bundesgerichtshof
bundesverfassungsgericht also es kann
ein sehr langes weiter quälen des
verfahren sein was die spd noch viele
lange jahre beschäftigen kann ich als
anwalt von thilo sarrazin hoffe nicht
dass es dazu kommt wir glauben derzeit
an die kraft der argumente von thilo
sarrazin wir glauben an das was er
gesagt hat was er geschrieben hat wir
sehen darin keine hetze oder ähnliches
es gibt keine presserechtliche
gegendarstellungen gegen seinem buch es
gibt keine strafanzeigen gegen ihn es
gibt nichts gegen ihn und wir glauben
einfach dass man auch in als einfaches
parteimitglied was thilo sarrazin ist
ohne funktionen in der partei dass man
als einfaches parteimitglied durchaus
ein buch schreiben darf das kontrovers
ist
aber diese kontroverse diese inhaltliche
kontroversen muss innerhalb der spd
ausgetragen werden und nicht über ein
ausschlussverfahren nicht über druck
sondern über diskussion in einer sehr
diskussionsfreudige partei